contre le coc u19 les chercheurs de
l'institut pasteur sont mobilisés leur
objectif trouver un vaccin capable
d'éradiquer l'épidémie
depuis l'élaboration du vaccin contre la
peste en 1885
l'institut s'est plusieurs fois illustré
en matière de découvertes scientifiques
voici quelques exemples début des années
cinquante à l'institut pasteur la
poliomyélite occupait l'équipe du
chercheur pierre lépine
cette maladie infectieuse touchaient des
dizaines de milliers de personnes dans
le monde
on sait trop que cette maladie peut
aboutir à la paralysie
avec des séquelles plus ou moins
définitive et qui de toute façon
nécessite une longue rééducation après
plusieurs mois de travaux les recherches
aboutissent
le vaccin contre la polio est prêt pour
être efficace la vaccination exige trois
injections espacées d'au moins un mois
sans oublier l'injection de rappel un an
après dans les années 80 les
scientifiques s'attaquait à l'hépatite b
pour la première fois des équipes du
professeur thiollet de l'institut
pasteur et du professeur chan et de
l'inserm ont réussi par manipulation
génétique à l'introduire dans des
cellules de souris et à produire ainsi
des antigènes c'est à dire le principe
actif d'un futur vaccin
le vaccin contre l'hépatite b voit le
jour en 1985 une révolution médicale
notamment dans les pays d'afrique où la
maladie déciment les populations
toujours dans les années 80 le sida
préoccupe les chercheurs de l'institut
pasteur
à cette époque le sida faisait des
ravages
face à l'une des plus grandes épidémies
du 20e siècle les équipes de pasteur
était encore une fois mobiles
les recherches se poursuivent et c'est
une équipe française qui ici à
l'institut pasteur isole la première le
virus en 83 la même équipe vient tout
juste de réussir à cloner ce virus
c'est-à-dire à le faire se multiplier
artificiellement laboratoire une étape
décisive dans la connaissance de la
maladie dans les années 90 la découverte
du gène de la dépendance à la nicotine
faisait partie des victoires de
l'institut que dans ce laboratoire de
l'institut pasteur
on vient de découvrir l'endroit du
cerveau secoue les récepteurs qui
provoque justement la dépendance à la
nicotine une étape clé pour
l'élaboration de nouvelles méthodes de
sevrage des fumeurs dans les années 2000
les chercheurs identifient l'origine de
l'épidémie de chikungunya un virus
transmis à l'homme par la piqûre du
moustique tigre cette épidémie est
causée par un virus originaires
d'afrique mais transportés par un
moustique originaire d'asie et cette
rencontre a lieu pour la première fois à
la réunion et donc on pense que le
moustique que le virus a dû s'adapter à
ce nouveau moustique qui ne connaissait
pas aujourd'hui l'institut pasteur
compte parmi les meilleurs centres de
recherche mondiaux
il compte dix prix nobel de physiologie
ou de médecine parmi ces scientifiques
[Musique]